the swelling crowds surging the U.S
Southern border marked the end of
pandemic era immigration rules between
Mexico and the Texas border wall now 4
000 U.S troops joined thousands of
border control agents at the Vanguard of
an effort to push back the swelling
human tide our borders are not open
people who cross our border unlawfully
and without a legal basis to remain will
be promptly processed and removed El
Paso's Sacred Heart Church has long been
home to about 200 migrants many spilling
out into the streets surviving on
donated food and bathing Outdoors lately
the numbers seeking Refuge has spiked
there were up to 1200 people around this
area on the sidewalks on some of these
side streets earlier this week U.S
immigration agents moved them for
processing ahead of the expected surge
to come
these are the lucky ones the migrants
who arrived and avoided deportation from
the U.S before the end of title 42. the
pandemic era rule that allowed the U.S
to turn away 2.7 million migrants over
the past three years Darwin trekked from
Ecuador on foot and entered the U.S
through a hole in the border wall in
search of a new life
I don't have anything I want a better
future so I can work so I can help my
family now migrants who cross won't be
immediately expelled from the U.S but
the new rules are strict
anyone seeking asylum in the U.S must
first show they've sought it elsewhere
and been rejected a bar few can meet
those deported can be excluded from the
U.S for five years but the lucky ones
who make it to this side of the wall
then begin a second Journey Through the
Asylum court process and that can take
years
suwani received the papers that let her
pursue Asylum this week she fled
Honduras with a daughter that she says
was persecuted for being a lesbian
I want a better future for her and I
want to help my father he's older now
Alejandro is one of 30 000 migrants each
month from Venezuela Nicaragua Cuba and
Haiti who were allowed to enter the U.S
through a new humanitarian parole
program
what I want to do is work
as The Surge of migrants Rises on the
U.S border many will likely take their
chances with illegal Crossings joining
the millions who already live in
Twilight status John hendron Al Jazeera
El Paso
well Alex Miller is from the America